so we've been talking about mel who's
this kind of like mythical is he
mythical
do we know he's a real person so yeah
mel was a real person in
i think 1956 to 60 when uh
computing was real cutting edge and
memory was at a premium
so i think he had 4096 bytes to work
with or something like that so
uh luxury luxury yeah every bike counted
so we did the self-modifying code and as
ever on youtube there were some comments
saying don't tell me what to do i'll
self-modify my code if
absolutely yeah putting that to one side
um what's the next sort of chapter in
the story then
well this sort of brings it all together
as uh sort of the finale of the
thing which uh is comes back to the
email that
uh came around in goodness days when
early on in the internet anyway when
people were discussing these real
programmers and this guy sent this story
of mel
we should do real there really shouldn't
be real yes the real programming so
this is not what you really want to do
because although it works
great it's almost unmaintainable
so the story goes that he worked on this
royal mcb
computer which um i've never heard of
before or since but it was quite popular
at the time
i believe and there's a new version of
it coming out and
whenever they went to trade shows they
always
sat there in front of this computer and
got people to come along and
play and they had a blackjack program so
anyway this blackjack program was really
popular so he was asked to port it to
their
brand new machine with this 4096 bytes
of drum memory
and so on okay got it all running and it
was all
working perfectly and it was very very
popular at shows
but then the sales people said this is
all great
but unfortunately the program beats the
customers too often
isn't something we could do somehow to
uh just just install a
you know something to tip the odds in
the customer's favor and you know
this would really help us sell a few
things you know just create a nice
atmosphere and mel was
no not keen on this that's no that goes
against all my principles for
changing this and that and anyway he was
lent on apparently by management and by
other people
and so on and you know we really need to
do a little bit more just to just to
help the sales of this thing
come through so eventually he uh decided
okay he would and there was a switch on
the front of the computer
it was to signal something but anyway he
could tap into that and say right if
this
button is pressed i'll i'll do something
so he wrote some new code to say if the
button's pressed then i'll stack the
odds slightly and did that produced it
and sent it out when they tried it out
it turned out that it actually stacked
the odds in the computer's favor
and not not the customer's favor and mel
thought this was great apparently he
thought this was uh you know this is
justification that you shouldn't try and
fiddle with the
you know the the probabilities and so on
and you should just play the real thing
so
uh he refused to fix it and actually
went on to
work somewhere else i don't know where
else he went anyway after mel had left
to go to passages new the guy who posted
this
he was brought in by management and said
mel
did this change and unfortunately it
changed in the wrong way
can you go and have a look at the
program and just adjust it and fix it
and his uh his comments on that were
quite a revelation he said you know i
knew mel was
quite a smart guy but you know i looked
at this program and i just couldn't
really understand how it's going i spent
a couple of weeks
pouring through the details it was
bringing in code it was modifying it
changing it putting it back things like
that
and he said the absolute ultimate uh
bit was where i came across a loop
that had absolutely no exit so the code
went into this loop and it just
continued forever so i'm sure you've
done things like this you know in the
early basics you'd do you know 10
print hello 20 go to 10 run and they
would just you know
print hello continuously so he found a
loop like that in the code
and just couldn't explain it every time
he ran it
it ran through the loop exited perfectly
and he just couldn't figure out how this
was happening
this is one reason why self-modifying
code and things like that is just so
dangerous and dangerous absolutely i
mean when you're writing it
it seems like oh wow you know i'm sort
of on the cutting edge here i've found
this great
hack here that can cut through things
but you give it to someone else and they
just
can't understand it you know without
considerable
amount of effort there are cases where
it is useful
but usually this is sort of generated by
compilers or things like that
where people sort of uh letting the
machine do the modifying
and not not the users directly modifying
it
anyway this this loop it turned out it
was running right at the top of
his available memory and although the
machine had index registers where you
can automatically apply
an offset to something so it's typically
used for stepping through a raise you
you say
go and read this information from this
bit of memory but add in this index
register and that will sort of move you
along
the memory without having to change
anything else he didn't use index
registers they they were
they were far behind he actually read in
the instruction with the
address which was attached to it and he
incremented the address
in memory and then would re write it
back so he would be changing the code
all the time
what mel was doing with this he was
incrementing these instructions
and stepping along this array or
something like that
but at one point because it was right at
the top of the memory
you would increment it and it would
actually go beyond the biggest
integer that would fit into this bit and
actually overflow onto the next bit
so this would set the the sort of bottom
few um
bits to zero and it would overflow
a bit into the next bit of the
instruction
and this would change the instruction
which was probably a fetch or something
into a different instruction which
happened to be a jump so it would get to
this point and what would normally be a
fetch
suddenly changed into a jump to location
zero
and it jumped to the beginning of the
program which was where it needed to go
anyway
so would sit in this loop and then some
part of it would overflow
changing the actual code change the code
in from a fetch into a jump
jump to the beginning of the program and
carry on as though nothing had happened
but there was no way of seeing this
apart from completely pulling the whole
program apart
pulling it apart and working through
exactly what was going on here and
finally finally the light dawning that
oh okay
i can't yeah because if you just looked
at the code it was just fetching
instructions instructions and fetching
bits of memory
and there was no no jump out of the loop
whatsoever but
yeah finally he managed to work out that
uh you know the critical thing was that
you were not only modifying
the address you were reading from you're
actually going to modify the instruction
so at this point he threw his hands up
went back to management and said
you know there's actually no way i'm
going to be able to change this program
it's just so
so intertwined and you know if i do make
a change here it's
going to fall apart here you know i'm
just going to leave well alone and
you'll just have to set it with the
switch and the customers will just have
to play it on the regular blackjack
setting but the other bigger thing which
sort of pervades the industry now is
don't try and be too clever
you know if if you are extremely clever
then
the people that come after you who have
to look after the code are going to be
spend so much time understanding it
that you know you might save a few
milliseconds here and there
but actually you're going to waste hours
and hours of programmer time
trying to understand this what you're
doing and and fix it
so you know the the moral of the story
is
being too clever can be uh be quite
quite
uh quite an issue for you later down the
line i was trying to think of a good
analogy i was kind of imagining like
you're driving the car along
and you can't work out why it turns
corners you shift yeah into third fourth
fifth gear and the sixth gear starts to
turn the wheels suddenly isn't
it oh i wasn't expecting that but
whenever i get to this bend i've got to
change your gear and that'll turn the
corner
yeah it's yeah but do we know what
happened whatever happened to mel did he
just
retire no it says in the story that he
went on to pass his new with a few
dollars
associated with it so he probably got a
better offer to uh
go and do something else which and uh he
does end up with saying i wonder if
you know mel was ever embraced the new
idea of
you know sort of object-oriented design
and
testing and all this sort of thing or
whether he was probably still
twiddling bits and uh look looking for
shorter cuts that
uh and he probably thinks that he he
he'd probably stick with the uh
the twiddling bits and uh working close
to the metal as they say
yeah it seems to me like he's the sort
of person who thinks in binary
very much so yes remember that
and in modern cpus you would have a link
register
of some sort that remembers didn't have
that in the very early days
but boy did it dawn on them that you
needed it someone voted for my oh it
doesn't even
let you vote for mike might be a bit of
favoritism in the voting his sister